le gouvernement déjà ce qui est parti ce
qui prépare secrètement à nouveau
confinement ou est-ce que c'est
nouveau confinement c'est exclu non rien
n'est exclu nous nous battons contre un
être vivant oui et il faut utiliser
toutes les armes qui sont à notre portée
aujourd'hui
ça paraît difficile d'appliquer un
confinement en tout cas un confinement
comme lors de la première vague
d'accords pas qu'on filme en général
mais un couvre-feu c'est possible c'est
possible aussi la situation se dégrader
je veux dire qu'on avait à l'époque je
me rappelle c'était ça qui est des fous
emmanuel macron avait dit si on a plus
de 5000 cas par jour on passera en
confinement aujourd'hui on a plus de 200
milles mais c'est vrai les règles les
régles ont un peu changé oui voilà c'est
normal que l'on changé ce qui reste vrai
c'est que l'hôpital est sous tension il
avait l'hôpital était en difficulté
depuis des années c'est pas une
nouveauté donc il pleut sur du mouillé
donc l'hôpital aujourd'hui est encore
plus en difficulté sur une difficulté
structurelle
nous avons une difficulté conjoncturelle
c'est le virus s'est en plus des départs
de certains personnels qui sont épuisés
serait grande lassitude
on peut le comprendre vous ça se voit
dans d'autres qu'on vaut rien qu'est ce
qui ferait qu' un couvre feu je pense
qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait beaucoup plus
de décès beaucoup plus de patients qui
rentrent en réanimation donc largement
la science puisse pas garantir l'accès à
la santé de monsieur tout le monde nous
l'a enlevé une appendicite demain un
infarctus j'espère que non et vous
arrivez à l'hôpital et on peut pas vous
prendre bordel où il a effectivement
un regard
circulaire
la cadoterie moi non
donc non pour l'instant donc c'est pas à
l'ordre du jour pour l'instant c'est ça
ça je ne penche pas d'accord non mais ça
c'est une grande question que se posent
les risques en politiquement le
gouvernement jusqu'à maintenant a
toujours été timoré appliquer des
mesures plus lourdes même lorsque la
scientifique le demander donc là parce
que c'est une c'est un choix politique
un restaurant vont rester ouverts stores
en bas on peut imaginer que si vraiment
il y avait une explosion du nombre de
400 mille
cd personnes qui sont infectées c'est ça
ce ne sont pas des personnes qui sont
malades des personnes qui ont besoin
d'aller à l'hôpital et encore moins des
personnes qui ont besoin d'aller en
réanimation donc pour le moment la
situation est plutôt favorable dans ce
champ cela donc sur la première question
vous l'avez compris pas de confinement
voilà priori à moins d'un drame que les
réanimations je crois que la france peut
accueillir jusqu'à 9000 réanimation et
landana 3008 c'est ça le vrai signal ces
trois minutes sur 9000 alors nous on
fait la france normalement à 5 pouces
emilie de raisin 1717 il y en a on
pourrait monter jusqu'à 12 milles ouais
d'accord le problème c'est que monter
c'est pas le problème c'est pas les
lignes et les ventilateurs la france est
riche acheter des lits construire des
murs mettre des ventilateurs c'est pas
le souci nous aussi c'est personnel un
lit de réanimation s consomme énormément
personnel des médecins des infirmières
des aides soignantes tout un système
logistique et c'est ça que nous n'avons
pas ce que nous n'avions pas un hôpital
n'est rien son échéance il travaille et
ce qui est fou c'est qu'on a continué à
fermer des lits jusqu'à maintenant vous
avez parié depuis tout à l'heure on
continue à percer le parapluie puisque
même les gens qui sont pas vaccinés on
leur dit restez chez vous on les a virés
on les a poussé à la démission alors moi
un personnel puis on vire les gens et
maintenant on rappelle dans rappel des
gens à la retraite mans en est on marche
sur la tête en vérité